so here's my first example that I want
us to walk through you can write it down
if you haven't already how do we work
out the area bounded by that curve y
equals sine X the x axis and those are
the boundaries shown not a 2pi just the
standard values okay now what you to
remember do you recall what was the big
issue we had in the AP 3's with the
extension exam there was one skill that
you kept on trying to avoid now is
graphing right now you are not asked to
graph in this case however it is
struggling and bad Dages to you if you
do even if it's just a rough one so you
can see what's going on so would you
please draw a small set of axes for me
it's not 2 2 pi so we only need the
positive side actually I'm going to draw
it over here
and this is just standard old vanilla y
equals sine X so that's roughly what it
looks like okay don't worry too much
about making this beautiful or pretty
like this question is not about the
graph the graph is just a stepping stone
tool but I am gonna put down some
boundaries for example that's zero
what's his end point over here that's 2
pi we should be started to get a little
more comfortable with that so therefore
if I want to work out the area bounded
by that curve the x-axis between here
and here what is the area how would you
describe it verbally hmm it's like this
son who's kind of camel hump shape here
right and then there's another like
antique um hump down here and they are
remember think about all the patterns
you ready here they're gonna be the same
size aren't they okay so I'm just going
to shade them in here just so my brain
knows what it's doing okay so how I
gonna set out our answer well the first
thing I'm going to do is to say to work
out this area I need to form the right
integrals okay so remember the question
does not say integrate we're gonna form
integrals ourselves it's an area so am I
thinking about signed area positive and
negative or am I just thinking of things
in terms of positives it's just in terms
of positives right that means I have to
be careful because an integral just from
naught to 2pi you should be able to tell
me with no calculation if I integrated
sine X or not to do pi what would you
get
you'd get zero that would be the signed
area this camel hump and this eighty
camel hump would just cancel each other
out okay so I have to for my integral a
little more carefully I'm going to do I
set this into two separate integrals
from naught to PI that's the positive
part and then PI to 2 pi is that okay so
let's write this out
not two pi
I've got no space now I'm gonna put a
minus sign there instead of a plus
because yeah this integral here I know
if I just go from pilots your PI will be
negative but I want it to be positive so
this negative sign cancel that out if
you prefer you can say plus and then
throw an absolute value sign in there
they end up being the same I would
prefer to do that because it's more
succinct anyway so PI to 2 pi ok and
it's the same function yeah do you have
a question ok could we use the fact that
it's symmetrical
yes please use the fact that it is
symmetrical however I'm going to just
say I would encourage you to write this
line first before you use the fact that
it's symmetrical because look at what
we're about to write on the next line
and I want you to notice how it's
actually quite different to this right
what Aaron's suggesting is this thing
here this second integral it's the same
size as this integral do you agree
which one do you think is easier to
evaluate the first one is right why it's
zero we like zeroes right so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to say to lots of
the first integral
should give me exactly the same thing
okay now I'm not going to write this
first because it doesn't take into
account all the information in the
question does that make sense but I can
say this clearly goes into this and I'm
even going to give a reason you don't
have to write this reason the marking
will be quite happy if it's not there
but I like to write it number one
because it's clearer number two so that
my brain knows when I come back to this
in the middle of an exam and I look at
these two lines and don't remember how
they're connected because that was like
an hour ago in the exam this tells me
how they're connected there's symmetry
to this graph okay
we've done we've used our properties
here we've felt about the signed area
we've thought about how to use our
properties can you integrate for me
choose out the front what does sine x
integrate into very good negative cos
you've already been exposed to
differentiation and integration enough
to realize it is tricky it is easy to
mix up differentiating that would give
you cause which is like so close it
looks really good but it's not okay so
it takes some time to get more
comfortable with this there's an upper
and lower boundaries that negative sign
I'm going to factor it out because it's
independent of X that leaves me a
negative two and then when I evaluate my
heart my upper and lower boundaries I'm
just going to write it in UK with that
happy this is one of the reasons why in
earlier topics
even though sorry earlier kinds of
different integrands even though zero
you would evaluate that and it would
often just come out as zero like with a
polynomial here you can see that's not
the case is it positive zero is so not
zero okay so therefore you have to be
extra careful
cos of Pi cos of Pi hmm what my brain is
doing is it sees the COS curve right can
you visualize the cos curve pi is
halfway across and it's right down there
at the bottom of the value so that's
negative one
what about cos zero positive one because
the graph starts up there and then it
comes down minus 1 negative 2 times
negative 2 gives me
four so just to be really neat I'm going
to conclude could you just slap unit
square on the end of your working yeah
it'd be okay but I think this is nicer
than leader and a bit clearer how do you
feel you okay with that you can see how
much we pull down our prior knowledge in
order to just like even get started on
the question you can see there's little
traps to fall into like integrating sign
integrating cause instead of sine or
whatever one last thing I want to know
do you think it's unusual this area is
so weird and wobbly and curvy but it
comes out to such a nice round number
does that feel weird to you like it
feels weird to me I want you to think
back unfortunately a lot of you went in
this class last year so some of this
would be a little bit confusing but I'll
explain to you afterwards if you like I
want you if you were in my class last
year to think back to that rocket do you
remember the rocket we were talking
about integration and why it gives you
area and Russell drew this really great
rocket with an astronaut in it and you
know all I kind of think and we said
when you integrate right it's like
moving from velocity or speed it's like
moving from velocity or speed to
displacement or position do you remember
that
that's what integrating is kind of like
right when you integrate velocity you'll
find out like where have you changed
your position now have a look at the
curve that is the primitive of that
negative cos x what does negative cos x
look like we know what cause looks like
what effect is that minus sign have at
the front it flips upside down so I
think this is what negative contacts
would look like yeah so what this here
no well what the whole question is
saying really from here to here it's
asking this question what's the total
distance you've traveled the total
displacement right after starting here
at zero and ending over here at two pi
can you see why the answer is four where
does it start he starts down here at
negative one right and then where does
he go he travels upwards right like this
he stops at this spot how far has he
traveled at that point he's traveled two
units from negative one all the way up
until one so there's like that journey
and then he does the return journey and
goes another two units back so he ends
up where he started
but he's gone four units in total in his
round trip does that make sense now I
just put that there just because it sort
of rounds out that metaphor we
introduced before if you weren't here
when I introduced that metaphor and
you're confused don't worry too much but
I'm we're going to come back to this
idea when we look deeper into motion the
next term and so far that in the back of
your mind that there's this relationship
between the two